Your dribbling won't get you through
No, I
see through your choices and everything, and Liu is waiting
But this road is my aim
I'm the only one who can see ahead and move on in this change of circumstances as we rush in front of the goal As everyone competes for the course, it
completely disappears from Rin's corpse and strikes at once I
broke through diagonally only in haste
[Music]  ] It's the
future of the guild that I
envisioned My decisive opportunity My direct absolute
territory It's a lie Even though I
got out of it perfectly The
distance between the shift blocks that caught up with the fog
Senpai
[Music] You can read
me through and catch up to me Because you're a
genius,
this is my true last action
[Music]
[Applause] I'm
going to surpass you